ministre la parole est à monsieur jean
pierre door merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à vous monsieur le
premier ministre
après la nuit noire apocalyptique du 13
novembre où la réalité effectuant la
plus barbare a dépassé toute fiction
nous sommes en deuil et nous sommes en
colère
monsieur le premier ministre les
médecins les chirurgiens les personnels
de santé ont annulé unanimement leur
manifestation de ce même vendredi 13
contre le projet de loi santé
ils ont respecté leur serment
d'hippocrate
ils ont pour beaucoup participé au
soutien logistique et médicale
toute la nuit du 13 novembre et nous les
en remercions chaleureusement monsieur
le premier ministre c'est à vous que je
m'adresse
c'est à vous que je m'adresse loin de
toute polémique
loin de toute polémique de notre part le
groupe l'est républicain vous pose la
question comment pourrait-on envisager
un débat sur la loi santé actuellement
ici dans l'hémicycle vous n'ignorez pas
l'opposition et la réticence à ce texte
un texte sculpté qui déchire un texte
qui oppose alors ne légiférer pas par un
passage en force de la part de votre
majorité
ce serait irresponsable en cette période
de deuil national
le moment n'est pas venu et il n'est pas
de votre deux roues il est de votre
devoir de nous entendre de nous écouter
et d'écouter les professionnels de santé
donc de reporter ce débat ne les
entraîner pas à reprendre leurs
manifestations
le débat sur la sécurité et l'état
d'urgence annoncée hier est primordial
il est prioritaire pour tous les
français vous avez aussi annulé le
congrès des maires reporter en 2016
alors ne fragiliser pas l'unité reporter
également le texte santé en 2016
je vous remercie madame marisol touraine
ministre des affaires sociales de la
santé et des droits des femmes
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député jean-pierre
door
selon le dernier bilan dont nous
disposions il y a actuellement encore
dans les hôpitaux de paris ou de la
petite couronne
221 une victime hospitalisée 57 en
réanimation et c'est à ces hommes et à
ces femmes qu'aujourd'hui à l'instant où
je vous parle vont mes pensées et c'est
aussi à l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé qui vendredi soir dans la nuit et
depuis se sont mobilisés d'une manière
absolument extraordinaire
et nous voulons leur dire voulons leur
dire notre fierté devant le travail
absolument exceptionnel qu'ils ont
réalisé le samu les hôpitaux parisiens
et les hôpitaux de la petite couronne
les hôpitaux militaires de béja et de
persil qui ont travaillé dans des
conditions extrêmes et qui pour autant
ont rendu une médecine absolument
exceptionnel je me suis rendu sur place
pour leur rendre hommage et rendre
hommage aux victimes
les dévots du le débat sur la loi de
modernisation de notre système de santé
a été reporté à jeudi après la
discussion sur l'état d'urgence et je
suis certaine qu au moment où ce texte
sera débattu dans l'hémicycle
nous aurons tous à l'esprit et au coeur
le formidable engagement des
professionnels de santé en particulier
dans nos hôpitaux pour faire en sorte
que la tragédie que nous avons connus ne
se redouble pas d'une tragédie
sanitaires merci madame lamic